it's been running themes as the two boys
youngsters try to learn how to win
Jimmy Potter the tears then Jesus cannot
miss room down to him
unfortunately our fantastic director
Dave different ways so fans about didn't
see what the crowd was ready Jimmy
Butler however excellent three-point
shooter he's starting to be established
himself in his lead one as well as Wiles
is playing Butler hangs in the air
kisses out the last like their chances
of getting to 86 tonight him up to 58
Denver Nuggets largest comeback and win
this season 18 points they did it twice
once against New Orleans and once
against Chicago and Jimmy Butler
get this thing to the finish line Butler
that is a tough shot got Jimmy buckets
Jimmy Butler shoots it over the top of
the smaller killer game win streak
matches their longest Butler and Jimmy
does it again the 40 seconds to go
Butler with the ball in his hands Jimmy
attacking hangs in the air finishing
that's all he knows gorgey sets the high
screen to free Jimmy for the day
the great way to put a chin can they
take advantage Butler
pulls out judge it by two you don't
think this guy's an all-star